my question now is about the seats you
sit in and and how you see yourself from
where you started to where you now are
right it's not just it's not about the
billion let's let's take the money and
put the money to the side for a second
let's talk about the accomplishment
let's talk about what you've done and
now the doors that have opened up and
how your view do you do you find
yourself in awe of what you've been able
to accomplish yeah yeah I've actually
was on on FaceTime with Ty today Tata
you know well
um and I was saying like I don't think
people realize that we just sit around
all the time and like can you believe
this [__] you [__] believe it I can't
believe this [__] that I've been able to
do just the end of the place where we
from and where we come from like
everyone has that story right we are
from
tough locations and that's just the way
the world was set up but just like the
things that we all were able to overcome
and where we sit now today you know and
as far as like you know success I just
look at it like all the people that I
was inspired by like Muhammad Ali was
like he gave me my bravado you know I'm
like when people see that I'm like I
have total belief in myself not because
it's it comes from a place of like
arrogance and just this pompousness it's
just like I felt proud like in a place
in a time when we all become uh were
being called ugly when Muhammad Ali was
like I'm so pretty I'm the greatest and
like people paid to see him lose
that's what was drawing his fights like
people come in there to see him lose
because he was so confident in his
ability and not not be not again not
from a place of arrogance because he
knew he put the work in one and two he
he lift us all up so you know I hope
that at the end of this journey or
however it ends out like I represent
that to you know
um as well like you're a piece of that
I've seen you make that change though
I've seen you make that change in growth
and in person
um just in conversation information that
you've started to put out right like you
know it made a shift from money I'm
getting it where you're not getting the
life that I'm living to what we as
people need to open our eyes to what we
need to understand what the
opportunities are where the real wealth
lives and lies like there there there's
been a significant just change in person
even that like even that if you look
back to reasonable down listen like even
the songs that were like more
braggadocious and out there and about
money were really more so directed at
like the system in America right you put
us in these situations and you
handcuffed us and you you put it behind
our back and we still made a way we
still you got took the music took the
drums we beat on the table you know what
I'm saying like you know you you stole
the um you made like blackface
we create a soul music you gave a scrap
we made soul food like everything that
was presented to us
um we made a way where we made a way so
even even in those songs it's like
almost like like like a
you know you know like a peacock like
spreading his wings like you know we
made it like so the transition has
happened you know because with more
information that you get you you evolve
and you grow but even even a minute my
first album came out in 26 so politics
is usual and those songs really dealt
with it regrets on my on the last song
on my first album you know that was a
real topics the evils you know just
talking about you know the relationship
and how money can come between friends
you know we we haven't had money for a
long time so we don't know how to we're
not professionals at navigating how to
communicate
you know I mean like you you know you'll
have people that where you come from if
you behave in a certain manner that
ain't it's not accustomed to where they
are right some people have been involved
past 16 they still stuck in that place
but you evolving every year so that may
be a threat to them
subconsciously or consciously and they
kept acting funny because you have to
navigate that you have cousins you got
to go home for Thanksgiving and people
are talking to you like Kevin Hart and
you going home for Solace you want
family you're going home for peace of
mind you're gonna hope for peace of mind
you're not cousins in your grandma's
living room saying yo man I got this uh
I got this play I Wanna you if you just
give me you know what I mean 4800 I
could make you 2 million you like it
don't work like that man you gotta
explain to him like life isn't like that
if money isn't free and no one's giving
out opportunities if it sounds too good
to be true it's really and then he like
oh you don't believe in my dreams
[Music]